Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to "You Have 10 Seconds"
...which is supposedly a very fast paced
and energetic game
where you are supposed to be doing these platform things
and not die.
And you have exacty ten seconds
to be able to do the things that it wants you to do
before it kills you DEAD
...and I don't know how I work under pressure
but obviously (this word is mumbled and jumbled) you guys know I don't do too well
and hopefully it's going to be okay
..I've never played it before..
Oh look, the threat of death is abong us (above + among?)
who the hell is that ?
Okay
alright then
well so far so easy this is
Ooooh no..
I spoke too soon!
Oh god no
of Fuck
Aah come on!
Ah cock
Oh this gonna be impossible... HEH-UH!
OOH COME ON! Piece of shit! Get out of my face-
Aright' hang on. EUH!
There we go! There we go!
god dammit
flipping it upside down
oOAAHH OHH GAWD
hep
..okay
got it. Alright
Shit
Shitty
Ah fuck!
alright..
WHAT??!!
OOHH I had a certain number of lives?!
OOh what a load of bullshit!! I gotta go b-
AOHh I only have 2 lives!
...that's such shit
How are you supposed to be able to do that!?
Awh god that's awfull!
OOh so awfull
Hanhe  shit
shitty tits
shitty biscuits
Agh Cock ass
Okay we'll try this again..
ah jeez
eeEEGH!
Oh, was I suppose to-
Oh that was an extra life!
Aw I should've picked that up before I thought it was a thread of death
I mean, when everything else is gonna be a thread of death
How am I suppose to-
*Strange noises*
How am I suppose to assume that anything's good in this world?!
UUUUGGGGGGGHHHHHH
fuck
bbbrrAAGH
there we go
alright
hUP
pew
hoop
heep
hooop
Okay, so far so good. I don't know how I died on this, it's pretty easy...
eEH
eEEGHH
EEGH
EIIGHH
okay
So far so good
oh what is THAT?!
Oh! Jump twice? nice!!!
Twice is nice
YEAAAHHHH!!!
I di- oh.
Eheh- It cuts to silence there.
eeh EGH
Okay, so I got the double jump now so hopefully it's gonna be a bit easier for me but I don't know about that
(Slips into an unknown struggle language)
(more struggles)
Okay, so far so goo
oh jeez what is what??
ooAAGHHH
WHAT HAPPENED?!
oh god dammit!
da-AAUGHH
fack youuU!
aaWW FAKAFF OFF
AAAWWWWWW
What a sack of asses!
What a bag of dicks!!!
W-w-what a satchel of... poop!
Ah god damn it, my brain's not working fast enough, obviously I'm not going to win this game if I can't think fast enough
Just think about it- oh FUCK YOU!
Ah god damn- ah FUCK OFF!
...I think that needs goin'
Gh-
FUCK
God-
Fucking cock-a-dick!
Fucking-suck a chode!
Fucking-bitch-aloid
Cock-ass and slap backs and-
Fuck you!
Ya
Friken...
Euh, there we go.
Euh
The thing is I'm trying to rush it, I'm trying to be all...
All
Hip and cool about things and I should realise how
Ab-
*Deep, soft and manly voice* oh fuck you...
At least it's gonna give me unlimited free lives there!
That's oftly nice of it!
Euh x4
Okay...
...we got this...
Hoof
Oh man. Fuck this and it's stylistic bullshit!
Oh god oh god
Oh shit
Did I fuck up? Why'd that happen?
I don't know
Ah gad
Ah gad!
Ah!
AH!
Ah gad!
Okay!
Jesus!
This is getting a bit too complicated now!
I don't need all the stress!!!
Don't need the stress!
Okay, so far so easy.
*soft* ah
Fiiiiiiiiiiiiiiine???
Fiiiiine???
Okay
Everything's fine!
*Mark's Mating call*
What's that mean? What's with the green?
Fucking cock!
Ahhhh! Okay
Straight down-
Ho-
He
HEE
Okay
Here we go
We got it
Is gud
IS GUD
Oooh! I got goggles!
Under water?
That's handy I guess?
Okay?
What is this?
*Four "ehs"*
Okay
Fine
Alright
Everything's in an extreme panic!
Eh
oh gawd
Man I used to play games like this all the time on Newgrounds and stuff
Oh-  OH Fuck off with you
Eh AW COME ON
Oh I get it! That reverses  the gravity! Okay
Fucking
*Strange Mark noises*
Okay so I gotta
God damn it!
Stop being...
Oh fuck off I wan- aAAGH
*sounds of rage*
I WANT it!
Uuugh I don't want it, I don't need it, it's a red herring, it's not what I'm supposed to get, it's not important (sure...)
I- oh fuck, okay, we're fine
It's a red herring, I don't need it!
it's- ohh fuck, I need it!
Oh god- OH GOD NO!
Oh oh oh oh
WHAT??! I MADE THROUGH!!
*sad music plays*
Fuck that shit! Bullshit!
Oh piece of ass
Piece of CAK
*slight Irish accent* What a load of dick
I made that hundred percent! okay
Ok, so here...
*laughs* It was like Flappy Bird!
Holy shit!
I don't wanna play by your rules!
Oh god not enough time
Euh
Oh god the jumping's not responsive enough
*nervous sounds*
Ok, so far so easy!
Oh geez what is this? What is this?
Ehhh! I'm not ready! I'm not ready!
Ehh!
Ah shit!
Ah shit dude!
Running outta time!
Ehh- aAAUGHH! I WANTED IT!
I wa- oh fuck off!
OH FUCK OFF!
I'm jumping!
Oh geez, man, geez. Oh fuck you! God dammit!
Why can't-
What can't jump- oh jump is space, I was using the 'up' arrow, which was entirely stupid of me (n00b)
Ok, that's- that's- this is much easier
Ok, that- that's much easier
ok... now I think I can actually...
I'm pretty sure I can- ooh- Ohh fuck off!
It's stupid, it's stupid, I shouldn't go for it- OH FUCK OFF!
Eh! Fuck you- god dammit! I have no lives-
AUGH! Fuck, man!
Fuck you!
You sack of shit!
Ugh, cock
*sigh*
This is why I can't play frustrating games, they just make me so mayud
They get my blood pressure up. My doctor hates me.
Hm, ok, easy
Okay easy easy
easy easy
Oh shit, oh shit
Okay that's fine
What - I just - I fucking am
I'm like spamming it
Oh come on
There we go, there we go
Ok, wegotitwegotitwegotitwegotit ok!
Huuuu duh ok easy easy easy
Babudh babudh, ok
babudh babudh
Oh fuck I didn't see where I was!
Ehhh!
Okayokayokayokay
EH YEUH!
Augh, there's more?! Ohh, 'B', down?
Down? Ohh, I gotta hold it down, ok
Alright, now we got a magnet and we've got that bullshit, that's gonna be-
Ugh, cock'n up our shteez!
Eh, eh, eh, ok...
So I now gotta use timing on the magnet
for only ten seconds to be able to do this bullshit?
eh, eh, eh, ok, that's easy enough
Wooo
I'm getting better at this guys, I'm getting bettter
getting better, getting better
Ooooh fuck off, what happened??
What happened?? Ohh it's in there
i didn't see where- Fucking
Criminy in here are you serious?
God Damn it
So don't panic
Fuuuaa- Fuck off
How? *laughing* Wh- what happened??
Ahhh God damn it
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
alright
it's fine, it's fine
ok
Not that
go there
habudbuski
eh, eh, ahhhhh ok got it
heh
ok
oK
Aaahhh ok
Yes, alright
I don't even know what happened but i think i won.
heyeah
heeeeeee ok
gOT IT, GOt it, GOT IT GOOd
OOOooOOooh there are spikes there
eh
eh, eh hehhhee
hee
heh he
ok
*strange noises*
Easy
Got it
Heh
What does that mean?
Ohhh
Ok
Yeah
The red one means it does NOT do the opposite of what I do
But that one was easy
Why was that so hard?
Okay, easy, easy enough
Okay easy enough
Gave me another one. Prepare myself
I don't like this s- oh gawd
Oh gawd
Oooh fuck no
Oh god no
Euh
Okay
Euuuuuuuh. Okay
Ooh God this is going to be impossible - AWAH FUCK OFF NO
NO
DONT' DO THIS TO ME! DON'T DO THIS TO ME!
IT WAS SO EASY LEADING UP TO THIS
I can do this - it's simple
AWAH FUCK OFF
WAAAUH
One last chance - I CAN DO THIS
OOOH I CAN DO THIS
*strangled* I can do this - I can do this - I can do this
UUUUH
Ah why is this so difficult this is simplistic stuff
Ooh jeez, ooh jeez Scoob. Ooh jeez Scoob. Thanks for having my life counter right there Scoob
Ooh jeez
Ooh jeez. Ah. Okay. okay
It's fine. Ooh jeez - it's fine
Ooooooooh-whooooa woooah
Okay. Okay
Everything's fine. Ooh jeez. Okay
Oh boy.
oOH BOY. Okay. Ooh jeez
UG-AAAAAAH FUCK NOO!
AAAH NO!
AAAH NOO NOOoooooooo! Come on!
Oooh fuck man, I gotta go through all that againnn?
God damnit!
Awh. Sack of shit
Oh I got the life!
Holy shit!
Can't believe I got the life!
Ooookay
Alright
That's why they made this - like - easier than the other parts - like -
The levels leading up to this are not terribly difficult like-
If I'm not a panic MESS I can get through them okay
So this is it, okay. This is it.
Alright, I got three lives going into this. I just can't waste them.
Woh! Here we go!
Waaah whahaha no what happened there?
Three lives can't waste them
Eugh! I got ROBBED! IT ROBBED ME!
Eug! Oh fuck. Ah jeez. Ah jeez
Thank you life counter. You're a life saver
Oh boy
Euuh euh
Euh-kay
Euuh euh - okay
Euh. Alright
I got this
Okay - okay. Here we go
Euh uh
EUWH COME ON! FUCK OFF
I GOT THAT! I PRESSED IT! I FUCKING PRESSED IT!
I NEED A KEYBOARD CAM TO SHOW YOU GUYS THAT I'M NOT AN IDIOT
I fucking PRESSED it
God damnit, Okay
I got two more chances
I can do it on this one. I don't need a second one
Euh uh. Okay.
Euh-euh
Eug
Euug
Euuug-eug-eug-eug-eug. Okay
I got this
Euh-uh-OH
OOH-AAAAAH YAAAA
OOH I DID IT YA!
THERE'S NO MORE RIGHT?! NO MORE  IT JUST SAYS NEW GAME
FUCK THAT SHIT! IM NOT DOING THAT
OKAY SO THAT IS "YOU HAVE 10 SECONDS"
I BEAT IT FAIR AND SQUARE. With only moderate amounts of rage
So that was fun *sniffles*
I had a great time with that! Very stressful. Very down to the wire. But I loved it a lot. So I hope you guys enjoy it too
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-byyyye!
*Standard upbeat outro music*